Well, I clearly got the answer wrong
being that I was rejected twice.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Seems to have worked out for you.
[LAUGH]
>> Let me start with that, so
look you're all young, you want to achieve
and you're in that first third part,
I describe my life in this these three
thirds, you're in the first part.
But if I would give you some advice and
I'm going to take some poetic license,
I'm not going to say one thing.
>> Please.
>> I must say two or three things,
here's my view of things now
that I'm a little older dog.
Number one, choose to have kids or
not, but if you choose to have kids
invest in your kids,
that's to me is the most important thing.
Second, go for it, have success,
but bring others along with you.
If I look at my professional success,
when I was in sales if I shipped
a computer to somebody else's territory.
I would send an email saying
I think you should get half
versus the managers having to be involved,
I remember it started then.
If we do something well it's the quiet, so
we will take as many people with you for
the ride as possible.
If you come across a jerk, let them rot
in their misery, just get away from them.
And number three,
bring it every day, get up,
I'm telling you there
are some days I go home and
I am just beat my god,
how much more can I do this?
A good night's sleep, I get up in
the morning and you bring it again.
Fearlessly, just go, go, go,
those are the not the most important,
but that's how I view through life.
And you've heard it before, think of life
when you've got a half hour left to live.
You're not going to think about boy,
my net worth is X,
it really should have been 1.2X,
I doubt you're going to think about that.
Boy, I only became CEO or
VP, man I wish I became EVP,
you're not going to think about that.
Now clearly you have to achieve success
because that's why you're here because
you're motivated.
And I don't want to short sell that
one bit, but I think in that order,
take care of the kids, your family.
Bring as many people as you can and arrive
with you and get away from the jerks.
And get up in the morning with a good
night's sleep and does bring it.